after tonight what is the future of the
country for the next four years well if
it's Donald Trump is president tonight
we are going to be seeing lawsuits
against media we are going to be seeing
cracking down an independent reporting
we are going to be seeing potentially
the holding open of Supreme Court seats
maybe even four years as we've heard
from Donald Trump's fellow Republicans
we are going to need strong independent
media if Donald Trump is the next
president of the United States because
corporate media you are not going to get
what you need from corporate media now
if Hillary Clinton wins tonight uh more
than likely it wouldn't be a further to
the right than Obama presidency but it
probably wouldn't be further to the left
either unless we activate and corporate
media is not going to do it uh it
whatever issue is important to you in
the next four years whether it's trade
the environment women's rights LGBT
rights education whatever it is it is
going to be influenced by media coverage
of that issue over the next four years
and whether it's Clinton or Trump
corporate media is not going to be the
place for the coverage that progressives
actually need so this is my election day
appeal to you hopefully we've all voted
by now or will within the next few hours
the next step is we need your support to
fund the program over the next four
years and the way to do that is through
membership you know that independent
media was instrumental in so many of the
movements that we have seen go viral
over the last year the entire Bernie
Sanders I would still call it a success
even though he ultimately lost and look
at what ultimately of Bernie Sanders
ideas made it into the Democratic party
platform much of that success was
because of independent media much of the
coverage of everything from the Dakota
access pipeline to thinking back further
Occupy Wall Street the real coverage of
these issues was not on corporate media
it was an independent media like the
david pakman show so i'm asking you
today on election day we're talking
about a few pennies a day for a lot of
great member benefits including members
only pro
ramming go to david pakman.com slash
membership and sign up make the
commitment because whether it's trump or
Clinton independent media needs to be
supported and because we have this end
of the year calendar thing going on if
you want to support the show I would
love to send you a free 2017 david
pakman show calendar filled with
original comic book art from artist and
david pakman show viewer dan burke go to
david pakman.com slash calendar 17 sign
up for a yearly membership through that
page and we will send you the calendar
for free let's start off we still have
until January for the inauguration but
let's start off the next four years and
two months really strongly properly
funding independent media because
corporate media has failed everybody
during this campaign and I'm asking you
to make that commitment to the show
please do we'll be back after this